foreign
if we can go through the um
pre-meeting instructions to us all uh
welcome to everyone and I will now read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest fire exit the two fire
exits through the partition doors are
currently not in use due to ongoing
Works therefore the fire exits through
the main doors of the hall or the
storeroom adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is around about
Island in front of the main entrance to
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded please
switch off mobile phones or turn to
silent please toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
members of the public while you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
getting used to the routine here
um
so uh
I would now ask officers to assist into
yeah right okay we don't need to do that
bit
okay
members and members of the public good
evening and welcome to uh this meeting
of the executive uh on Tuesday the 6th
of December 2022.
apologies for absence the only apology
that I've received is from councilor
Mike Webb
moving to item two non-members attending
I can see councilors sure councilor Hoy
councilor Foster and councilor Stanley
and thank you very much indeed for
attending here tonight so and other
members of the public thank you
right we moved to
item three on the agenda minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of November 2022
members they have been circulated can I
take them as an accurate record are
there any matters arising from that
those minutes
none
you agreed that I can sign them okay
thank you thank you very much
to receive any Declarations of Interest
members are there any Declarations of
Interest this evening on items on the
agenda nope
we tend to
question Phi uh to item five which is
questions on notice from counselors
members um there are three questions
that have been brought to my attention
uh this evening
and all three questions and I think the
maximum you're allowed an executive have
all been taken by councilor Stanley so
if I can invite councilor Stanley
perhaps to come to the seat here and
have a microphone in front of him and if
you would like to pose your first
question please councilor Stanley
when you're ready
thank you chairman
um
my first question to you
as leader of the council does the leader
believe that Fusion had fulfilled its
past obligations to maintain rdc's
assets
do you want me to read all the questions
one at a time I think that's the way to
do it because you do have of course the
right to ask me a supplementary should
you wish to develop any of my answer so
you know we take them each one at a time
if that's all right thank you
um but in response to that question
thank you very much indeed earlier this
year I was pleased to meet with the new
chief executive of fusion lifestyle
we had a positive conversation during
which I stressed the importance of our
Leisure facilities through our community
and the need for ongoing investment
Within These facilities and I assure you
I stressed it in the most strongest of
terms because of the importance of
leisure facilities in this District we
also discussed the investment that
Fusion had made into our facilities in
the past and where future investment may
be needed
given the past two years of the covid
pandemic we also discussed how the
Leisure industry nationally and fusion
locally continue to recover from the
pandemic that had such a devastating
effect on the industry as it did on many
sectors
I am pleased to report some recent
investments into our Leisure facilities
including new boilers serving the
swimming pools at Clements Hall Leisure
Center
refurbishment of the sauna at Clements
Hall Leisure Center
new studio floor at Clements Hall
Leisure Center
external cladding works at Rayleigh
Leisure Center
redecoration of external adapting at
Clements Hall at Leisure Center
in addition both Leisure centers have
received a brand new state-of-the-art
gym equipment and spin bikes
and this investment totals nearly one
million pounds
I shall say that again this investment
totals nearly one million pounds and is
a clear demonstration of fusions as well
as the council's commitment to the
health and well-being of our residents
I'm also pleased to report that this gym
equipment at both sites is accessible as
part of the strategy to offer an
inclusive Leisure service within the
district
going forward as part of Fusion's
program of agreed works the following
will be also completed
there will be new boilers at Rayleigh
Leisure Center
a new main hall floor at Clements Hall
Leisure Center replacement insulation on
ductwork on the roof at Clements Hall
Leisure Center renewal of fire alarm
system at Radio Leisure Center
redecoration at both Leisure centers
members will recall that the Leisure
contract was extended in December 2020
as a result of the impact of covid-19 on
the Leisure industry and to ensure a
sustainable Leisure service for our
residents
I'm proud that this forward-thinking
Council made this decision to safeguard
our future Leisure service for the
benefit of its residents a decision that
secured investment in our Leisure
facilities secured local jobs and
ensured our Leisure service was well
placed to provide for the needs of our
community in the future
and I would just like to remind members
and councilor Stanley that we put in 430
000 pounds at that time
against much questioning
um but my personal commitment was to
ensure that we protected jobs as well as
the Leisure service that we provide in
the district
to have received nearly one million
pounds back on that investment I think
he's far better interest than you would
get on your current account it's
something in excess of 100 return on the
investment
as part of the contract an agreed
programmer works for Fusion to complete
before the end of the contract has been
agreed this will build build on the
previous investment of works I referred
to earlier in my reply and will continue
to ensure that our Leisure facilities
receive the ongoing investment required
and I'm truly grateful to you councilor
Stanley for asking me that question
thank you thank you chairman
um whilst I do applaud the amount that
has been invested in those two units
that we are considering or what I'm
asking about
um my I also raise
um why has RDC not pressed Fusion to
meet these obligations in the upkeep of
Mill Hall and Castle Hall
together
sorry councilor Stanley could you just
clarify your point what obligations bear
in mind my last answer are you saying
RDC hasn't met
um
should have RDC a pressed Fusion to
carry out
uh better facilities in Mill Hall
and Castle Road Castle Hall
where the facilities of what has just
been explained to me for
Clements Hall and
um
Brady Leisure Center
some money of that some part of that
should have been put into Mill Hall and
Castle Road I believe
and why has why have we not pressed
Fusion to do that
councilor Stanley I think the investment
in Leisure facilities in this District
have been brilliant when you look at
adjacent districts and boroughs
I went through the detail or in my first
answer for exactly what has been
provided
nearly a million pounds return
for the 430 000 that we put in to
support jobs support Leisure facilities
and actually keep leisure in our
district afloat
so there seems to be a presumption that
we could have pressed even harder
um well with respect you weren't in the
meetings that I had but it's difficult
to know how I could have pressed harder
I accept that there's still room for
even better Improvement because that's
how I operate
um you know I always look for the next
level of improvement
um because we should never be complacent
with that so if you're alluding to the
fact of
do I think we can do more yes I will
always push for more but in terms of the
investment by Fusion I think it's been
absolutely brilliant but you have to
remember
other buildings we took out of the
fusion contract or you know we we
mothballed this building for example we
must board Castle Hall
we must board Freight house while we
concentrated on the Leisure providers in
the district I don't know whether you've
got another another question you want to
ask me yes uh just the last one yeah
with the asset delivery program has
included the requirement for Castle Hall
to be disposed of
has this now changed as the leader has
said if you don't use it you lose it
right I think my reference I think I'm
being misquoted I think my reference to
use it or lose it was specifically to
this building and whilst I seem to have
been quoted on all sorts of social media
channels in other channels as in fact
say derogatory comment
um I think it's quite clear that for any
facility for any product to carry on
being required or used you need to
actually show that there's a market for
it and all I'm doing is actually
appealing to people to use it to the
maximum so that we get an economic
return for the use of it so I don't
quite know why Mischief has been made of
might use it or lose it comment but I
repeat it understand by that comment and
to be absolutely clear Castle Road has
never been part of the asset delivery
program I don't know why it keeps coming
up as being mentioned as if it is I've
said repeatedly it is not part of the
asset delivery program it's managed
under the council's Leisure contract it
is currently mothballed following a
decision of the executive in December
2020 as a result of the impact of
covid-19 the council will continue to
explore the options for alternative
commercial or Community use for Castle
Hall
and that remains our position but my
determination
my personal determination is to make
this building work and be an example of
excellence in Rayleigh as it is to make
Freight House an example of excellence
in Oxford
just one last comment if I'm a chairman
thank you for the answers that you've
given I'm satisfied with those answers
at this present time okay can I ask you
would this be a phase two of the asset
delivery or the Leisure facilities that
we are now seeing as Investments that
are going forward
uh
sorry I have to ask you to clarify the
question okay
um
I've seen what you said as phase one of
the investment being made from not only
Watford District Council but from Fusion
themselves
can I see a phase two where this is some
of the money or some monies is going to
be put into Mill Hall and Castle Road
councilor Stanley I refer you to my last
answer where Council road is concerned
uh Castle Hall in respect of this
building there's no question of phrases
I am personally committed the executive
are committed to making this building a
success I was proud for it to be
reopened it remains opened and we're
talking about sustainability of its use
um please don't underestimate the
challenge of making that happen but you
have my I look you squarely in the eyes
when I say you have my commitment that I
and my executive colleagues are doing
everything we can to make this a
sustainable
um sustainable
area
thank you chairman thank you very much
thank you very much thank you thank you
for taking the trouble to write those
questions thank you
right we move on to um
matters referred to the executive and
reports from other committees and
there are none
taking item number seven which is uh on
your agenda which is the future Leisure
service provision to consider the report
of the director of assets and
Investments setting out options for
procurement of a Leisure operator
partner to deliver the council's Leisure
facility provision from the 1st of April
2025.
I'll start by saying members that as
councilor Webb is not attending this
evening I will be introducing this
report as leader
in December 2020 the executive agreed to
extend the current Leisure contracts to
2025 due to the obvious challenges of
procuring within the Leisure market
during the pandemic this report sets out
our intended approach to procuring a
Leisure operator partner for both Rady
Leisure Center and Clements Hall Leisure
Center by 2025.
and seeks the approval of an earmarked
Reserve to fund essential activities to
support that procurement process
I will now invite Phoebe Barnes where's
Phoebe she's over there I will now
invite Phoebe Barnes director of assets
and Investments to give us a technical
introduction to the report uh thank you
Phoebe for attending tonight over to you
thank you so the current service
provider is Fusion lifestyle this was a
20-year plus three-year extension
contract which started in 2002 and is
due to end in 2025. and the council's
Leisure centers are significant Council
asset and is providing important
services to the community they serve so
early consideration of the future
options for this Leisure facility
provision is therefore important
officers have considered all options
regarding how the council could operate
East Leisure centers with limited
resources and finances the recommended
option within this report is to Tender
the contract for an operator partner
model this is how we're currently
operating the Leisure Services with
Fusion currently
sorry I couldn't hear myself very sorry
for apologies
um the figures that are quoted within
the port within the report are quite
healthy estimates and they are based on
some benchmarking officers have carried
out with external partners and suppliers
the purpose of this funding is to ensure
the procurement process can run
competitively in a timely manner and be
successful in appointing the right
operator
um so just to go through some of the
points that the report is highlighting
and the purpose of the feasibility study
is for the council to understand the
potential of its Leisure sites to ensure
it's offering
um the offering that's made at these
sites is future proof it will help in
form of procurement exercise by
identifying opportunities for investment
and to look at increased capacity across
both Leisure sites the condition survey
is needed to build into the procurement
pack so bidders are aware of as well as
the council is aware of the state of the
buildings going into the new contract
um the report also mentions funds to be
allocated for external Technical and
legal advice
the council doesn't currently have that
internal resource to write a bit of this
scale or require funds and do this to
ensure it's compliant and successful
there is an opportunity under the
partnership with Brent Borough Council
to share costs if they tend to Brent was
contract went at the same time just to
highlight that Brentwood haven't made
that decision out their own governance
decision yet around that
um so therefore any decision that
Brentwood makes would obviously be
reported back
um so kind of the total funds identical
support it is an investment
they're looking for the new contractor
either save money for the council or to
try and be a commercial contract where
we're looking at a profit share with the
new provider
um
so the council's receiving either some
Revenue some savings as well as a higher
quality Leisure service provider in the
borough as well thank you
thank you Phoebe I will just emphasize
one point there which I believe sort of
is still relating to councilor Stanley's
point and I really just want to put his
mind at ease that part of this process
is to make sure that the conditions of
the facilities when they were taken over
by Fusion are handed back to the council
for their new provider
um in the state in which they were
handed over with the exception of wear
and tear and I think that's an important
point so that is part of this evaluation
process which is a professional
evaluation process and I think that was
one of the points that you quite rightly
labored in your questions counselor
Stanley so and that that gave me an
opportunity just to go back and that's
in this report the importance of us
getting them back in the way we handed
them over
um so so at that point I'll turn to any
questions from the deputy leader she's
signifying she has a question cancel a
vote
thank you chairman and thank you Phoebe
um for me it is about the costings but I
think it's just the way the report's
written and I think going forward if we
can just explain more so that other
members of the council can fully
understand not to mention the residents
um
so I think we just need to tidy up on
those going forward
I can't support these recommendations as
they're written
um but I'll listen to what everyone else
on the exec says and then we'll go from
there okay thank you
thank you chairman
thank you very much any other members of
the executive cancer sparing
I think
concern is me I think you need to
microphone to look closer to you
is that okay chairman
yep thumbs up from the audience so that
sounds good enough to me I I think
in the past we've had a number of
Consultants referred to us
um who the council has used
um because we've used them before and
they've got a bit of a track record can
I can I make sure that
we don't just spend money on Consultants
that they have a specific task that we
want them to undertake that we cannot
cover within our own remits
and that if we can we use local
consultant or local technical people uh
don't want to keep using the word
Consultants that concerns me in the past
um if we can great if we can't I
understand that but I think we've all
learned from experience that
some of these uh and I use the word
Consultants then uh had free range we
were reliably informed how good they
were and I think it caused us concern
when we saw the result of reports that
were being submitted a lot of the
information well I think we were very
cynical about German that effectively it
was almost cut and pasted for what
they'd done to somebody else thank you
chairman I think your point well mate
thank you councilor sparing are there
any mum other members of the executive
councilor FD
thank you chairman um I'm looking at the
recall in 1.6
is undertake Community engagement
um I'm a little bit concerned it comes
in towards it's 1.6 not near the
beginning
so I don't know if this is going to go
in the timeline that he set out and then
we pull because I don't want the
community to be let down in that we ask
for something they don't actually want
so I feel that should be
up
one of the first things we actually ask
and do
thank you councilor ft
councilor Belton
thank you
um
yeah I agree with some of the points
that have been made reading the report
it was a little bit eye-watering to
start with but then having had some uh
some questions and hearing what you've
said makes a lot more sense and with
Council Arrow asking that we have a bit
more detail moving forward I think that
will help alleviate concerns
um certainly with the budget gaps that
are coming forward and that by 2025 and
onwards we're likely to be facing it's
pleasing to hear that we're taking a
commercial approach to this and actually
taking this forward as an investment
where we can save money and not just
rely on charges to to bridge that Gap so
that is something I'm I'm pleased to
hear
um regarding the expenditure being asked
to earmark or to reserve and
for me it's about where possible using
Specialists such as councilor sperina
said that are local we've got some
fantastic businesses and professionals
within the district and I would like us
to always look there first I know that
is not always possible bigger picture
but I certainly think we need to look
inwards rather than outwards where
possible
and also that where we're spending money
it is being used in a cost-effective way
and we're getting a good return on that
investment bigger picture we know that
we want to be commercial and that we'll
get that but make sure we get good value
for money in the short term as well
thank you thank you councilor Belton
any other comments from execute members
Council award
thank you chairman
um
there's a lot of things that have been
mentioned by other people in regards to
this particular
paper
I would like to see
the consolidation
is a bit bit closer to your mouth
should be loud enough turn it up
is that loud enough okay fine
um
I I'm not particularly happy about the
allocation of the various sums
to various things
I personally would have liked to have
seen just a one sum
so that we can actually monitor where
everything is just allocating
just as it is I'm not particularly happy
with
um I feel that it needs to be
incremental we need to look at
everything
that we're going to do I can understand
the need as you explained very
succinctly as if you are selling a house
you need to have a surveyor in to make
sure that what you're selling is up to
scratch and it's exactly the same with
these assets both of these Leisure
assets if we're offering them out to a
new tender a new user
we need to make sure that they are being
offered at the best quality and the same
as we offer them out originally to
Fusion so that's a very important factor
to make sure that Fusion actually put
back into
these two sites
how they receive them I think my
colleagues have have covered most
everything thank you
thank you any other executive members
wish to comment before I try and sum up
on the uh on the paper
I mean certainly when I first saw this
paper there were certain aspects and you
know it's healthy to have briefing
representation from other members and
feedback that I have received
um
coming to this meeting tonight
um I spoke to officers at length and
I will go through my following comments
and with comments and points that have
been made tonight very eloquently made
there are some new recommendations that
I should be looking for a second for
because I think
anticipating and thank you for setting
up the various points
given what I understood
was the feeling I think that may allay
some concerns Council of Roe alluded to
the various recommendations in the paper
so I'll go through and I'm sure that
you'll agree with me that it's
absolutely critical uh that we have a
robust procurement process and we
eventually get the right partner in
place yeah that is key to these
facilities
in a commercial and sustainable way
whilst The Upfront investment in this
process may seem large and it is it will
ensure that we are able to achieve the
best outcomes for the two sites and the
users of the facilities
we should very much
see this as pump priming investment to
ensure there is due diligence and we're
having the right contract in place will
provide as many benefits including
Financial in return
there may also be an opportunity to
share some of these upfront costs with
our strategic partner Brentwood Borough
Council as they consider their Leisure
contracts subject of course to their own
decision-making process
so the reserve we're talking about will
enable us to engage sector experts too
undertake a feasibility study which will
set out the opportunities for the
facilities within the current and future
Leisure markets and identify the capital
costs of any required refurbishment
works
this will ensure that we can deliver
ambitious and viable outcomes for the
sites
completes a current building condition
survey which will ensure that we were
able we are able to maximize
opportunities with potential operators
and ensure that we follow the correct
procurement on Contracting processes
specific to this type of service area
and I make the point
um and this is really new from where we
were 20 years ago with this contract
is we're really looking for operators
that have much greater commercial
awareness to give us a return
on the investment so that we're not
constantly putting money in and that is
the clever part of the procurement
process so that we actually get a return
on on the buildings return on our
investment
so with that in mind
um I'm happy to propose the following
recommendations which I've adjusted
slightly or considerably whichever way
you like to look at it
from those in the report to give greater
Clarity and member oversight to ensure
ongoing portfolio holder involvement in
the process
and I will go through each
recommendation in turn and we will vote
after each recommendation
and I go to 1.1 and that is to undertake
the required work
in consultation with the leader of the
council and portfolio holders
responsible for finance and Leisure
to procure a Leisure operator partner to
deliver the council's Leisure facility
provision from the 1st of April 2025.
when the current contract ends first of
all do I have a second for that
recommendation councilor growth thank
you for that
in that case members can I ask for those
in favor of the recommendation to
indicate with a show of hands please
that is unanimous
and likewise I moved to
recommendation 1.2 to an agree an
earmarked maximum Reserve
of one hundred thousand pounds to fund
the necessary activities set out in the
report to support the procurement of a
Leisure operator partner
any spending against this Reserve will
be agreed by the leader of the council
and the portfolio holders responsible
for finance and Leisure
again do I have a seconder for that
recommendation Council award thank you
for that and members can you indicate by
a show of hands if you agree with that
recommendation
that too is unanimous
I move on to item three 1.3 I mean
um and the recommendation there is to
undertake a community engagement process
to support the procurement of a Leisure
operator partner involving the relevant
portfolio holders
and again I'm looking for a seconder
please
councilor Belton
thank you and again I'm looking for a
show of hands if you agree with that
recommendation
and that is unanimous
and we move finally to my proposed
recommendation that progress with the
procurement is reported back to the
executive via portfolio holder updates
and that any further decisions required
by the council's governance arrangements
are brought to the executive for
agreement
again do I have a second
councilor sparing thank you for that and
finally on that recommendation
um can I please have a show of hands if
you support it
and finally unanimous thank you very
much indeed members
right we moved to agenda item 8 which is
an update on the cost of living crisis
who is going to introduce that report
foreign
good evening everybody so this report is
an update that has been
um
agreed that would come back to Executive
as members can see from the report just
provides an update of where we are and
what actually is happening future
reports will come back to Executive
unfortunately Tracy Lily can't be here
tonight but if I can answer any
questions I will if not I will take them
away and come back to members shortly
thank you
thank you Steve
um councilor ft
it's a quick question Steve
on 3.5 there's been a collaborate
collaborative work in
group has been established has there
been any reports back on that what's
happening with that other than a very
general what's been put in the report we
are
only in terms of them getting together
and sharing data the two tasks can
finish groups hopefully will provide us
much more information I will check with
Tracy Lily and come back to you though
if there's anything more that I can
share with you at this stage okay thank
you
any other questions
in that case I will turn to the decision
being recommended and that's at 1.1 that
the update on the cost of living
response and work of the cost of living
working group be noted is that noted
members
thank you very much
we moved to item number nine
which is a um
report on the
contract monitoring
and
nobody that uh are you reporting on that
getting nods there so
Naomi if you'd like to introduce a
report please thank you leader um yeah
members of the executive will note that
this is an annual report that you
receive just in terms of looking at the
major contracts that the council has to
manage and this particular report is
looking at the contracts are in place
for the financial year
2021-22
so just to note
um that obviously there has been a few
changes since then but the um yeah the
contents of the report are meant to
reflect the previous Financial year and
the position that we're facing then so
the purpose of the report really is just
to give you an outline of
um the the scale and scope of those
contracts and the contract monitoring
and management that's been in place over
that period of time and you're not in
the report that it refers to the fact
that in previous years external audit
have been interested both um obviously
in terms of our compliance against our
own country procedure rules but also
particularly where there's been some
notable kind of contractor failures at a
national level that they want to sort of
see that we've got adequate Assurance
around Supply continuity so this report
really seeks to kind of provide some
Assurance on that kind of level
obviously we can't report in every
single contract that the council manages
because they are numerous but
um you'll see it paragraph 2.12 that we
just list there the major contracts are
considered as part of this report and
then obviously the remainder of the
report sets out in more detail how those
particular contracts are being managed
um
this report was obviously prepared in
the name of the assistant director legal
who's now not here so I may not have all
of the um detail if anyone wants to
answer any questions but I'm sure I'll
be supported um with my colleagues if
there are any particular questions that
the executive wants to ask about any
particular aspect of the report
thank you very much indeed Naomi um the
definition of um uh by size it's over a
hundred thousand pounds as I recall
isn't it
so I think it was done on a kind of risk
um basis in terms of the kind of
comparative value so it was kind of
looking at the
um if we rank all of our contracts by
value the kind of top 10 but I don't
know if there was it was a specific
Financial limit that was kind of put in
place
yeah okay sorry yeah anything over
anything over a hundred thousand we
looked at along with the how the risk
was deemed against yeah against the risk
of it if it was a higher risk or medium
risk and the value thank you very much
indeed
right any questions on that report it is
a statutory report that we bring our
Council award
thank you sorry
well thank you
um I never primed you on this one before
but um how many other contracts are
there outside of these that have been
mentioned or are there too many genome
right
I would say there's too many if I'm yeah
and I only focus on the central one so I
only deal with anything over 25 000
pounds and then there'll be many smaller
value contracts that officers deal with
directly so yeah but I have there's a
there's a contracts register on our
website which has got
I wouldn't say 100 but we're getting
there with with all our contracts from
the council and and uh if I may just ask
a secondary one this actually refers to
councilor belton's uh inquiry with
regard to using local
people how many of those and I I know
you haven't got the answer but I would
be interested to know how many of those
contracts were procured locally
I can take a look and come back to you
on that I don't I do not know off the
top of my head and I would like that
answer and I think maybe can I just
clarify when you say local you mean
within the district correct okay that's
fine leave that with me and I'll come
back to you thank you very much thank
you councilor you weren't really
expecting an answer on that one off the
top of Lauren's head were you
um but but it is important that we keep
a focus on local providers where it's
all possible
um councilor councilor Anthony was next
actually you're deferring to councilor
Belton are you
oh okay
um it was just a general question
um as we've had a lot of conversation
around the Leisure contract and
obviously that comes up in here and it's
interesting to see that Clements Hall
underperformed in terms of number of
visitors quite substantially whereas
radio Leisure Center over performed and
I wondered how do we dig into that to
find out what is driving or not driving
as the case may be our residents to the
Leisure centers so that that for me
forms part of what we do next in terms
of the strategy and and the procurement
process and I just wondered what happens
when we get when you get this report
so I um don't manage the Leisure
contract I only gather the information
so that's something I'd have to refer
back to either Phoebe or one of the
other officers so we can take that back
and come and come back to you on that
point
yes I think that's a really important
point to differentiate between what is a
statutory report that we bring to
Executive for noting
um but also it provokes a number of
questions and certainly we hone in on
areas of underperformance and it would
be helpful because that isn't the core
subject tonight but I do think if
officers could take away where there is
a clear underperformance I'm sure some
of it used to do with covid and the
return but a bit ironic over the same
period you get a really good return at
Radio Leisure Center which is pleasing
to see and not so good and we need to
learn lessons from that you know you
know so it's a bit outside the scope of
what we're doing in terms of looking at
the contracts but it's an important sort
of aspect that comes to the fore
councilor Belton
to come back on that exactly for me it's
equally as important to find out why
things are not working as to find out
the things that are working so that we
can transfer those methods elsewhere if
possible
thank you very much
councilor Hefty I believe you're nice
exactly the same question I was going to
ask really so let me answer thank you
okay thank you any other
members coming up with any questions no
in that case
um I turn to um
item one 1.1 at one
um and the decision being recommended
that the contents of the report be noted
and it is duly noted agreed
okay and on that point uh I would like
to thank members of the public uh other
councilor colleagues
officers and members of the executive
thank you very much indeed for giving
your time this evening and that uh 20 or
10 hours 2011 hours it's just clicked I
conclude close the this evening's
executive thank you very much indeed
thank you